You're about to see a fascinating
conversation I had with Dave Ramsey
where we talk about how he makes money,
the advantages of inerson versus remote,
a project that he lost millions of
dollars on that I think has underlying
lessons that any business owner can take
from them. And finally, five stages of
scaling all entrepreneurs go through. I
think you're going to love it. Enjoy.
Welcome everyone to the game. I'm here
with uh Dave Ramsey, the man, the myth,
the legend. Honor to be back with you,
my friend. I'm so excited with
everything that's happening with you
guys. You're blowing up, man. It's pr
I'm proud to watch you. It's great.
Well, thank you. We're uh we're trying
to trying to follow in in the Ramsey
footsteps. There's so much stuff that I
had written down um and prepared for
today and I I doubt we'll get to to all
of it, but if you could walk me through
just kind of lay the land in terms of
Ramsey solutions as the business exists
today because I think it'll be helpful
for the audience to give context. Yeah.
What what ended up happening with us was
we classic entrepreneurs. um you know we
were um a wee bit ADD and so uh you know
just something something flashy and uh
shiny went in front of us. We would look
at it because but it all came through
the funnel of or or the filter of does
this serve our mission and our mission
is just to help people uh with common
sense education and empowerment in some
area in their life. It started in the
money piece. And so when I first
started, I was doing a free uh I was
working for free at a talk radio
station, doing a little talk radio show
on the local station and I print a
little book, started selling it out of
the trunk of my car. So publishing was
born, right? Uh then we did an event at
the local Ramada in so live events were
born and so each of these uh in those
days everything was analog. Of course
the internet comes along and one of
these kids working for me comes in and
goes, "Hey, we need a website." And I'm
like, "What's that?" And so we built a
website on one of those tiny little uh
antique. You ought to look them up.
They're cool. Those little first little
Apple computers, the first little they
look like a little shoe box. And uh he
built it built us a site on there with
Cole Fusion. And it was pitiful. But it
was still cutting edge. Uh it was a big
time deal in those days cuz nobody had a
website. We had one of the first people
had a web store to sell stuff because it
was a platform. Again, platform platform
platform. So, we're platform agnostic.
And anytime we see a an a new and or
emerging platform, analog or digital,
we're going to put our toe in the water
and keep doing the ones we're already
doing. We're not going to abandon them.
If they die on their own, fine. Uh if
something runs its course, we're done
with it. But, uh but but and you know,
we just go on and do the next thing. And
guy walks in my office in the early
2000s, we need a podcast. What's a
podcast? I don't even know what this is.
And we were one of the first uh
certainly one of the first in talk radio
to put a podcast out because the talk
radio people resisted it. They were
afraid it was competition. So on and on
and on and on it goes. And and now we
end up today we've got about 14 profit
centers here um inside the organization.
Today there's about,00 of us 650,000
foot campus that were uh you know that
you've been here and hung out with us at
our home and um and so we've got the
entree leadership brand where we're
teaching leadership and coaching small
businesses and we've got events around
that, books around that. The book we're
talking about today is from that that
idea. Uh, and we've got a huge coaching
business in that area, coaching small
businesses, uh, 200 and fewer team
members. And, um, we're not real good
with the large corporate goobers. We
don't help them much. So, um, and then
we've got the, uh, uh, obviously we've
got all the stuff in the money space.
Financial Peace University is now
digital. Uh, it's no longer a VHS or a
DVD or even an MP3. It's a digital
format. Uh, we're rolling that up into
slowly. Uh we're in beta to slowly start
to move pieces of that into the Every
Dollar app uh which is the largest
budgeting one of the largest budgeting
apps on the planet right now. We've had
50 million downloads with that. Um that
app is huge. It's exploding and it's a
fabulous it's very robust. Our tech team
has done an incredible job. So, that's
the digital very scalable thing, you
know, on uh, you know, one end of the
barbell. And then we've still got
coaches over on the other end. And we
still do small high-end ultrav platinum
events where 25 people go to my, uh,
event barn at my farm and hang out with
me for a weekend. Uh so we go all the
way we you know we stretch the spectrum
from uh the high margin highouch uh uh
expensive thing all the way over to free
on on the every dollar app or free on
the podcast uh consumption or the
YouTube consumption. Probably more of an
answer than you wanted but that we're
all over the place and all of these
things will have to do with just is
there another way to preach this
message? Is there another platform? So
we're platform agnostic. Someone said,
"You're you're a bestselling author."
No, that author is one of the things we
do. You're you're a talk radio guy. No,
but talking on the microphone is just
one of the things we do. Uh we're not
and we're not we're not married to any
of them. I got one wife and that's
that's
plenty. All right. I have I have a bunch
of follow-ups on that. So, with all
these different profit centers, number
one is
what you have 14 and it's been how many
is have been 40 how many years? 35
years. 40 years since you started. About
35 years. 35 years.
So, it's roughly like one profit center
per per two and change years, right? Two
and a half years almost uh on the nose
um that gets started. It's been more
than that because we've killed some
along the way. Yeah, even better. So,
what makes something worth pursuing
versus what makes something a no? Is it
just its on mission? Because I would
imagine that there's you have resource
constraints. You can't do everything
that you would love to do. So, what what
makes something quote worth doing versus
not worth doing? Well, these days we we
are much better. In the old days, I was
just we just did it. I mean, it was like
stupid. It was just stupid. And uh but
nowadays, we actually do run a beta on
something and we look at the ROIs and we
look at the customer acquisition cost,
the rorowaz, and so forth. And we're
looking at um you know is is this a good
use of our bandwidth of our marketing
bandwidth of our um of our leadership
time frame you know the time invested um
o overhead uh committed to this project
and so uh I mean we can you know we we
drop a lot of stuff in the test bucket
and uh but if it doesn't if it's not
going to have a great rorowaz if it's
not going to have a great conversion and
if it's not going to have a great margin
when we're done. Uh we can't afford to
do it because of opportunity cost. Uh we
can afford financially to do it, but but
the the missed opportunity on something
that was working 10x of what this little
thing that we fell in love with over
here but sucks. Um you know, we have to
just let the thing that sucks die. And
uh it didn't make it out of the test
tube. That's all it amounts to. You take
more of a a test test quickly, lots of
ideas kind of strategy. And if something
something hits then it's then you double
down on those things. Is that's kind of
how you think through kind of new
product or expansion of kind of like
profit profit centers I think is what
you said. Exactly. Or and or can can we
you know can we iterate it five or 10
degrees and cause it to work. I don't we
don't kill everything instantaneously
but I mean if we're going to invest even
enough to get it into the test tube
we're going to we're going to iterate
iterate iterate before we kill it. But
when we lose hope that the thing is
going to have have a scale or have a
margin that that is commensurate with
the uh with the resources committed as
you said that then you know when we lose
that hope we've got to be grown-ups and
go nah I really like this thing but it
just it's not not it's not good
business. So with these new endeavors,
the first thing I wrote down when you
started when you when when you brought
it up was was who does new and the
reason I bring this up because I imagine
a lot of business owners have many
ideas. You know, you said it earlier on
like shiny object like oh this looks
exciting, this looks exciting, this
looks exciting. But for something to
work, you typically have to have talent
overseeing it. And I would imagine at
the point that you're at now, you're
probably not overseeing each of these
kind of new profit centers or new ideas.
Maybe they're, you know, brought to you
and you review the metrics, but you're
not really driving, unless you are, in
which case this is an open question. Um,
who who does new? Because are you going
to take resources from something that's
working? Are you bringing somebody new
in or do you have a specific testing
department that's all they do and then
they hand it off to somebody else? Like,
can you walk me through that process?
Probably
a hodgepodge of a little bit of all of
that. I don't do it. No. Um but but what
we have created is this collaboration
uh freedom uh for anybody to throw an
idea on the table. Uh and then you got
to defend it. Uh you got to make a case
for it. Um and so you can't just throw
it out there and go, "Well, you guys go
do that now cuz I'm so smart I came up
with it." Because ideas are a dime a
dozen. People who can implement them are
the problem, right? Any one of the
profit centers, for instance, entree
leadership. Okay? So it's got several
components to it. It's got a digital
component. an entree leadership elite
which is a digital coaching product for
small businesses right so if somebody
comes in and says I got a great idea to
add something a tool to that digital
product or whatever that's usually going
to bubble up somewhere in that entree
leadership team from that that the vice
president who's running that Jason or um
you know John Falcon's our senior coach
over there so he's got a lot of co him
and his coaches they're on the front
lines they're they're interfacing with
the customer all the time the customer's
going to throw needs at them they went
okay we need to serve this need, how can
we do that? Is that a digital thing? Is
it a a coaching need? How are we going
to fill it? So, fill the need, fill the
need, fill the need from an
entrepreneur's perspective, but what we
do is we give a lot of power to the vice
president of that particular business
unit uh or sub business unit uh to
bubble things up. And then on top of
that, if somebody's in another whole
area, they're more than welcome to, you
know, pull pull the pin on a grenade and
throw it over in another area and go,
"Hey guys, I got a great idea over here.
I want to blow some stuff up." And so,
but again, you've got to defend that and
then you've got to defend the the
resource usage
uh to to to take it forward to take it
past gleaming idea that I had while I
was on the running trail this morning.
Uh which you get a new idea every
freaking morning if you're doing this,
you know, it's just and 90% of them suck
when they actually come in, but when
they're on the running trail, they're
all great, you know, before they see the
light of day in the actual business
climate. So anyway, I'm convinced that,
you know, everything Ramsay has done has
been on about 10% of our ideas. 90% of
them when they made the light of day
sucked. And some of them really sucked
bad, but you know, you you don't know
that sometimes till you get in there
swinging. So all that to say, it's it's
bubbling up. Uh
occasionally we'll have something that
doesn't have a home. Uh and we have a
special projects wind team that is an
incubator. It's a shark tank, if you
will, for for ideas that don't they can
jump in. And so you've got some senior
leaders representing several of the
disciplines that sit in there. And
special projects works on two things.
Broke things broke, you know, some an
area's got the flu and it's, you know,
we're not meeting budget, we're not
hitting our revenue goals, and it's a,
you know, it's a goodsized thing and
it's problem. I sit in that. I sit in
that work team. That's one of the things
I sit on. It's one of the groups of work
groups I sit in because I'm
entrepreneurial and I love working on
broken things. And we'll take a baby
thing in there that doesn't have a home,
an orphan, and um you know, put put it
in niku in there and let's get this
thing let's get it nourished. Let's see
if we can get it moving and um see if
see if it can survive. If we can get the
thing to where it's past beta and it's
actually the business is actually got
some social proof, uh, we'll make it a
new profit center or we'll drop it into
one of the existing ones that even
though the idea didn't come from them,
uh, and go, look, this fits over here
the best, so we're going to drop it with
you guys and um, and you know, we'll
take send a leader when we send it over
there. We'll put a new leader on it and
let and then start to staff it out. So
when you put a new leader on it that so
that was the who does new that was kind
of the heart. Um so when you put a new
leader on is that do you typically pull
like a junior like if you VP is head of
a division you pull somebody who's kind
of one of their right hand they get the
opportunity from a career pathing
perspective that they can run this new
thing or like how do you think through
through bringing those leaders in are
you mostly yeah I would just love to
know how do you think through through
that part?
probably 80% maybe even 90% of the time
it's in house and we're constantly
working on bench depth around here. And
so we've got somebody waiting in the
wings and it might be them that that
birthed the new idea and brought it into
special projects, you know, and so they
may have been rocking the baby for a
little while and then they just get to
they get to grow it on up, right? They
get to give the orphan a home and they
they become the new mom, daddy of the of
the thing. So um uh yeah that's how I
like to do it because if the person if
it was born in their heart they will
they will fight all the enemies
internally and externally for the
survival of their baby. I mean and
they'll champion the cause baby. I like
the pe I like champions. uh you know
they paint their face blue and uh you
know and you know ride a horse with a
big sword coming through the thing to
get every and and you sometimes you got
to sit them. I I would a lot rather try
to take somebody like that and pull them
back and polish them a little bit than
trying to light wet wood. Light wet
wood. That's a great analogy. Well, when
you when you start these new divisions,
and I think I I I want to the reason I'm
hitting on this is because I think it if
you asked a hundred entrepreneurs,
what's the number one thing that uh you
wish you could do? It would probably be
more new stuff. And so, this feels like
a very a very relevant thing to talk
about. And I think that happens at all
levels because, you know, in the
beginning, uh you're just barely
figuring out what's going on. And so,
you're just trying and seeing what
sticks. Later, you have more resources.
So, you think you can do more. Um, but
oftentimes you also distract the team.
They feel whiplash and then sometimes
the core business starts to falter
because everyone's looking at the new
shiny toy rather than the main game. We
started it with one area and it was tech
because tech was exploding uh 20 years
ago. And so, you know, we had the web
department, you know, that's what it was
called. That's how lame it was, right?
And so, but these so these these, you
know, these programmers and tech people
are all sitting in a room. Uh, but
they're getting paid off the P&L of that
profit center. So, the guy or gal
running that profit center wants some
freaking
accountability, but instead we had them
just over here. They were on their own
little island and we had to break that
up. And that's when we busted it. About
this about 20 years ago, we went to this
matrix approach. Well, this is a is a
great segue. Um, so with each of these
VPs, I would imagine these are, you
know, among the most valuable people in
the business, right? Because they're
they're fundamentally running a business
unit. Yeah. They got literally a P&L and
they literally get paid off the bottom.
They get build for portions of the
overhead, the rent for the building in
their area as if they were a, you know,
a standalone business, so to speak. So,
we're job costing if you want to use
accounting terms. And um, and then they
get paid off that bottom line. So if
they if their bottom line goes zoom
zoom, their personal income goes zoom
zoom. I I I want them to be very wealthy
because that means they made me a lot of
money and so I love it and uh yeah and
we want everybody in the building doing
that. Also though we have a high respect
for the seauite we have a high respect
for that senior marketer uh and the the
value that they bring not just the
entrepreneur running the the vice
president's role or again senior VP
sitting some of those and even some uh
executives uh some of our operating
board members sit in some of those seats
but um but that's how you know it all
rolls up under a business unit and then
the seuite I imagine gets kind of
compensated from the company overall.
Yeah, because what I've got is uh our
operating board is half seauite and half
business units. And so what we've got to
have is we've got to have this u uh we
have to have an accounting system and a
budgeting system that serves the
business units and notifies the rest of
us if the business how the business
units performing. And so uh it's not
really optional. You've got to do that.
And and if if you're a a bootstrapped
entrepreneur that came out of sales or
marketing, you might not know how to do
all that accounting stuff. And so I got
to roll some accounting support up under
you to make sure that that you get to
keep doing the stuff you're good at, but
we also actually want to count the
beans, make sure, you know, pay taxes.
Yeah. This stay open, all the good
stuff.
I get I get this question a lot, so I'm
curious your take on it. um equity
packages, stock shares, anything like
that or is it all pure based on bottom
line profit? Is that the kind of the
performance compensation uh component of
the the leadership that you bring in for
either business units or seauite? You
know, when we first uh started sharing
off the bottom line with people, that's
when we had to answer the equity
question was are we going to um let
someone have stock? Okay. So, our
endgame, we decided a long time ago,
endgame is not going
public. Endgame is perpetual operation
generationally. And so, it's what Simon
Senate calls the infinite game. Okay? We
So, we don't have an exit to an IPO
planned. Uh we're not doing that. We've
decided distinctly 25 years ago, not
doing that. We don't have a sale of uh
of any kind to a VC or anything else. We
don't have a liquidity moment anywhere
on the horizon at all. If you do, it
would change what you're doing maybe.
Okay? Because if you're going to take
the thing public and you give some
people some equity, that's not a big
deal. Okay? But if you're running at
infinite like that and um about the only
thing that we're 100 about the only
person in the building we're 100% sure
is still going to be here is
me everybody else could might someday
want to leave or have to leave. And so
uh uh and and I didn't want that. I
wanted everybody to stay forever cuz I
love our people and I I you know there
some of my best friends are my leaders
here that I mean we do stuff socially
with our wives and husbands and
everything else. I love them. I've got
high respect for them uh as human
beings, as their spiritual character,
everything. But still, I have over over
all these years found that sometimes
people leave and I cry a little, but I
cry a lot if they took stock with them.
And so, uh we don't have any equity
positions at all. And uh you you make
unbelievably good money when you move
into leadership and you're paid off the
bottom line here. Like lights out scary
good money.
uh like nobody nobody does what we do.
We're so freaking generous because these
are the people that are running the
thing. They're the people that grew
this. They deserve to get paid like
they're a partner. And so I I have zero
greed over that. But you don't own
anything. I own 100%. Well, I don't own
the stock anymore. My It's in my kids'
names. uh uh from a state and planning
standpoint, but uh and they're, you
know, my grown kids, my the the the
nextgen uh of uh grown Ramsy's. So, but
uh aside, I mean, I've got 1% to be
clear, but the only voting stock, but
the uh but anyway, no, there's no
equity. There's no equity anywhere
except Ramsy's. That's it. Oh, I love
that. Um I'd say Leila and I have a
similar perspective on acquisition.com
in that it's kind of our forever
business. you know, we plan on just
continuing to own it, continuing to
operate it. You know, we will we'll
enter we kind of see it as the goose
versus the eggs. Um, at least how how we
think through it, which is probably like
we use a different analogy, but similar
you have 14 profit centers. Those are
the eggs and then the goose. It's like
why would we get rid of acquisition.com?
It's it's the the mothership to to use
your language. So, it brings so that
brings up uh two two different points
that are probably somewhat related. So
one is is a 100% of Ramsey in person are
anybody is anyone remote? No, we all
work at work. Yeah. So there's no like
like you don't have like exceptions
where like you know vid uh like editors
or for for for social media or you know
maybe some of the coaches or something
like that could be remote. Everybody
moves to um to Tennessee. Yes. And
the with the exception of the occasional
temporary thing. Yeah. Of course.
obvious but in terms of the actual
structure and the reason is very simple.
Um our quality of communication
in-person communication quality goes way
up and so things are actually
communicated. We all know this. Anyone
that's got walking around sense knows
that 85% of communication is uh is body
language and tone and p not words. and
and so um uh when you are sitting beside
someone you can feel the spirit of
what's going on and you are getting a
whole different quality level of quality
of communication. What that does is it
increases two things. It increases
trust and it increases
productivity and and then those two
things increase speed because
organizations move at the speed of trust
and and so when I am not sure because
I'm using a text uh or I'm even a zoom
uh and I'm not really sure what she
meant or he meant. I can't really tell
if they were being passive aggressive,
but if you're sitting with them, you
know, right? If you're sitting with
them, you know. And I I can go just go
walk around the building and I can feel
the air. I can feel it in the air. I've
been leading a long time. And I teach my
leaders to do this. There's an old book
a thousand years ago, In Search of
Excellence. It was the Good to Great
book before Good to Great, before Jim
Collins did it. It was back in '92. And
um you know that they studied great
companies. And one of the things the
managers did, they did management by
walking around. Just walk the floor of
the plant if you're in manufacturing.
and feel the vibe of the workers. Feel
the speed. Feel the energy in the air.
Look for u chaos. Look for uh dirt and
filth versus organization. Um and I walk
through, I smell food inside of our
building. No, that's not cool. We have a
cafeteria. You don't eat at your desk.
Leave your salmon somewhere else. Nobody
wants to smell that crap, right? And so,
you know, they're just little stuff, but
you just walk through and you can kind
of tell uh, you know, I walk past
people, they're they're on a they're on
a co a coaching call on a Zoom call with
somebody. I just pop my head in there,
you know, smile, wave, and disrupt the
whole call and then leave, spread hate
and dissension, right? So, that kind of
thing creates a cultural
uh uh level of trust and productivity.
Uh, I call them driveby communications.
I can just drive. I can walk past and I
read through the weekly reports and uh
uh so and so's mother's got cancer and I
can walk past just touch them on the
shoulder and say, "Hey man, I'm praying
for your mom. Sorry about that." Third,
you know, 68 second interaction that
does not occur if they're remote. I
think you might like this. Um, I think
it was either Uber or Airbnb. Someone
can correct me in the comments, but uh
the they did a research study because I
think they were trying to prove or at
least definitively know whether in
person versus remote, you know, which
one is better, etc. And they they found
a an it depends answer which is and I
talk about this because obviously we're
in person, we have a big big
headquarters here in Vegas. um that
especially especially for the first
third of someone's career. So basically
like call it 18 to 35 is where those
people get a disproportionate upside for
being in person because of all of the
unstructured learning that occurs that's
not on your quote career path. You know
like if you're sitting right next to
marketing and you're in sales, you know,
you you overhear, you know, what what's
going on in terms of the organic stuff.
you over hear what's going on in the
paid side. You start learning a little
bit more about funnel, you know, about
landing page and conversion rates and
things like that. And then all of a
sudden when you are on a sales call, you
know, with a business owner or whomever,
and they bring something of that up,
you're like, "Oh, I actually know
something about that." Because but if
you were in an only Zoom environment,
uh, you lose out on all of that. And so
I'm a big advocate and because I
obviously have a um a big, you know,
percentage of the audience that I have
that's in their early 20s um beginning
their career. I would encourage you all
to to work in person. I really mean
that. I did read one I did read one
piece of research that you get more uh
uh chances at promotion. Oh yeah. In
person than if you're sitting at home
and you're only on the calls
commensurate to the task assigned to
you. And so and you know we can add to
this even further. you've been here. Uh
we've got this massive fabulous
cafeteria uh restaurant at Ramsey. So,
um and on top of that, we drop several
million dollars a year into that to
subsidize the food cost. So, you can eat
here for about half of what you can
drive down the road and, you know, get a
fast food burger or whatever. Uh why do
we do that? Because when people eat
together, oh, that adds a whole another
level. When you break bread with someone
else, it changes everything. And so what
happens is people that don't work
together end up eating together and what
you're talking about occurs. They learn
from each other. They uh you know, they
talk about stuff they're working on. Uh
sometimes they just talk about personal
stuff, but then the next time an issue
comes up, they trust that person because
they've actually developed a bit of a
relationship with them. I look over and
our tech guys and we got a bunch of
techies in here, a bunch of programmers
and stuff and they're all over there
huddled around some table playing some
weird board game thing that I don't even
know how it works. Um and and you know
that only programmers would play, right?
And um or some weird card game, Dungeons
and Dragons type stuff or whatever. I
don't know. And and but they're having a
blast and they're playing together and
eating together and that changes the
whole vibe of the deal. I will tell you
that if you just are only concerned
about a task and that's it, a simple
tactical do this thing, that's fine for
remote. But our stuff is always 100% of
the time we want more out of the
interaction than the simple task being
accomplished. And that's why we've stood
firm on this. And we've lost some people
to that. They want to go work and have
work life balance which or whatever they
call it. and so that they can work from
home. Uh but what that actually means is
I'm not planning to work eight hours,
right? Because if you're working eight
hours at home, you're not talking and
interacting with your family. So I don't
know how you added hours to your family
unless you're cheating the company. And
so uh uh I don't I don't I don't
understand it. But I'm not mad about it.
It's just why we've decided to do it.
And then but some people some people jet
and that we've lost some good people
over that. And uh so we've had a lot of
discussions about it here, but we're
pretty firm on that. There's a couple
dovetales that I that I'll hit on that.
So one is you talked earlier about bench
depth, and I would imagine that one of
the best ways to build the bench depth
is having more people crossunctionally
learning in person from other leaders at
cafeteria, at the water, break area, um
and what have you. You also spoke about
trust. Uh the speed of the company is
based on the speed of trust. And I would
um I would I would I I 100% agree. And I
think that translates into faster
decision-m. And so I'm I'm a big I'm a
big believer in the speed of decisions
is the speed of the company, which can
only be based on the trust that people
have. If you have to double check every
single thing, then all of a sudden
approval process has to get put in place
and then bureaucracy kills everything.
Well, and and it it it interferes with
delegation. The the essence of
delegation is
trust. And so when I can let something
bubble up from the bottom, it's because
I trust the people that they're that the
idea is going to get filtered and
vetted. It's we're not going to go drop
a million dollars on a bad idea, you
know, and so it's not I I trust the
competency of the people. That's a
that's a form of delegation. And I think
you spoke to two things there. You spoke
to both competence and intention, right?
So intention, you know, like are they
good at their job and do they do they
mean mean well? Which I think it kind of
ladders up to on brand versus off-brand.
Is this a Ramsay thing to do? Is this
the Ramsay way? Um, so if just because I
think everybody loves The Good Story,
what's the most what's the biggest goof
up you've had uh in 35 years on
something that was off brand for Ramsay
that you were like, "Man, I can't
believe we did that or I like and and
and what what then what did you do about
it afterwards?" Because I'm sure every
business owner's had a big goof up and
been like, "Shoot, that was bad." You
know, I I I I don't know if it was
off-brand, but
um I think one of the most expensive
things we ever did uh was that we got
about uh several millions of dollars
into
uh the uh building of a debit card.
Okay. A Ramsey debit card that it wasn't
off brand. It was right on brand. But um
but but what this it was one of those
things we didn't know what we didn't
know banking regulations and and so
forth. So we're looking for a click and
mortar bank to park the thing in cuz
it's we're not in the banking business.
We're certainly not going to open a
bank. Good lord no. Um that would be
there's no way. But but there there's
tremendous um revenue potential in the
transaction fees. And so we're looking
at the Ramsey debit card and it's
something that we could promote. We
could brand it. Had a nice little
gazelle on it. Had a nice little R on
it. That kind of stuff. And um we
screwed around that. That thing was born
in Special Projects Committee. It was a
baby. It was orphan. And we put it we
brought it that's an deal. We brought in
an outside guy that knew the banking
world and he's still with us today.
Works in another area. He was brilliant
guy. Really smart. And um I don't I
never want to lose the guy, but uh we
got down into that thing and it uh you
know, of course it's has to survive
through the pandemic. Uh and and that
that slowed everything down, shut
everything down for a while and had to
back put it on the shelf. Get it off the
shelf and dust it off. Okay, get it
going again. Get the beta picked back
up. Get the alpha picked up first and
get the beta picked up. And I think we
were at about 10,000 people in beta.
Okay. and
um the uh the the the um outside fraud
uh bots started hitting the thing and we
thought that the bank had the u the
software to catch all of that. Uh and
then we're looking at okay, we're
responsible for these overdrafts that
are being created. we have to cover them
um in our contract. And real quickly,
the thing starts going sideways. And I'm
like, man, I'm so many millions into
this thing. I really don't want to kill
this thing. But I we're looking at the
risk and the upside. And and we just we
blew it up. We killed it. And I still
got one of those little debit cards in
my folder. I carry it to remind me of
how stupid I was. We weren't stupid
really. We we did everything correctly,
but what we we were ignorant. We did not
know what we didn't know about what our
exposures were. And once those exposures
became
um evident, we just had to go, "Oh, this
is way scary. I can't breathe and we're
not doing this." Like, our losses could
be infinite. Huh. Yeah. Exactly.
Exactly. I'm like, "Yeah, if I write,
you know, if we lose the several million
we've got in it, that's that pales in
comparison to how bad this could be if
we don't stop. So, we're going to stop
now." And uh odd thing, the bank that we
were working with uh later went sideways
and was in the news and blew up. And so,
I think I think uh God protected us by
letting us exit the thing early because
we would have gotten the opportunity to
exit anyway or we would had to move the
whole project to another bank when that
bank blew up. But it was a
click-and-mortar bank thing. I feel like
a lot of people have had that same like,
"This is such a good idea on paper. Why
is this not working the way I wanted
to?" Exactly. And it was working. The
customer loved it. We would have been
able to track and for the customer,
track their expenses, and give them
report and feedback. The data we could
have reverse furnished back to the
customer was going to be Oh, man. It was
going to be beautiful. Oh, yeah. I mean,
I see it. It's a I mean, it it's
compelling. and and the you know and we
had written so many of the APIs and so
much of the tie-ins you know to get all
that stuff we're running it on every
dollar in the beta but
uh yeah it got it got hairy let me let
me pivot from something uh from from the
super tactical of that to zooming all
the way out so a lot of entrepreneurs
myself included you know you start to
you know build build a lot of wealth and
then there's also the biggest percentage
of your wealth sits inside of the
enterprise that you run, right? And so
how do you think
about family office like you know you
start you start getting this money right
that comes into the business or comes
out of the business excuse me. Um do you
have any kind of mental framework that
you work through in terms of percentage
reallocation to new you know new
investments uh within within the
overarching structure. Uh, and where
where this gets more tactical for me to
you is Leila and I have run almost
everything inside of acquisition.com.
And that means like we own buildings, we
own apartment complexes, all that. It
still sits in acquisition.com.
Obviously, there's entity structures and
things like that, but in terms of the
team that helps run it because, you
know, acquisition.com primarily is an
investment, you know, it started as a
family office, but it just it spun up
these other uh profit centers to use
your language. um over time. And so I
I'm I'm curious, have you do you do you
completely separate church and state to
to to use that language in terms of you
know Ramsey personal versus Yeah. Can
you just walk me through how you think
through that? No, we we have uh done all
other investing outside of Ramsey
Solutions uh and in separate legal
entities as well for for uh
riskmanagement purposes. That simple.
and also for estate planning purposes.
Uh so for instance, the campus that you
were on is um it's probably a $600
million asset roughly, something like
that. Um maybe you own in cash. Yeah.
Yeah. I just wanted the audience to I
just wanted the audience to know. Sorry.
Go ahead. So, when we when we bought the
dirt to start laying the first bricks on
the first thing on it, uh that was a $10
million purchase and it's the largest
purchase I'd ever done in my life when I
bought the dirt and I was freaking out
and I'm like now I got to build
something too. You know, now that I
bought the largest thing, now I got to
do something even bigger and it's like
we're going to cash. So, we cash flow
everything as you said. Um, but we
immediately drop that into the
children's trust so that I'm not the
owner and uh and so you avoid um any you
you don't avoid capital gains on the or
I'm sorry estate tax on the basis of
what you put in there, but you do own
all the growth. And so while we've owned
this property, it's doubled in value.
Um, and so there's hundreds of millions
of dollars that have now avoided uh
estate tax by that being over there.
Plus, if someone wants to sue Ramsay,
which apparently is a hobby for some
people, and uh then they uh you know,
that's not on the plate because Ramsay
does not own the campus. Ramsay is a uh
Ramsey Solutions is a tenant uh of the
Children's Trust. And then, you know,
same thing if we we own a bunch of other
real estate because I love real estate
like you do. and uh um I just buy that
and drop it into an LLC. And if it's
anything over uh 10 million, I drop it
into a sing single standalone LLC so
that all risk associated with that
property is contained within that
property. and uh from a latig from a uh
litigation standpoint uh or or maybe
anything else. But um and also then that
gives us some other estate planning
things we can do uh with uh because
partial interest LLC's can be with one
of the kids can be uh or a kid entity.
Uh a trust can be greatly uh reduced in
uh appraisal value. uh and you can slip
more and more of that into the estate
plan and not have taxes on it. So we've
been doing a bunch of that for 20 years
and playing with all that stuff and that
so the reason was estate taxes and risk
management is the only reason it's there
philosophically it's all in one lump.
Well, that's exact and that that really
teases to the the heart of it because
for sure the entity structure from a
risk protection perspective then you
know uh from from a succession planning
and avoiding estate taxes later that
100% makes sense. I was curious about
the actual team. So like would the same
legal team that does Ramsay stuff do
some of these other deals? I asked
because this is me selfishly asking
because my my you know my my estate
attorneys, you know, who manage all of
that stuff. Um and I have our M&A
attorneys that handle a lot of our our
our deal flow. Um a lot of times we
share I share the same resources, same
same people um for things that are quote
personal versus
acquisition.com. Um and I was curious if
you had any like basically if you had
had a mistake from that that I don't
know about, I would love to know.
No, I I have used uh I've done both. Uh
so all accounting for the whole thing is
in-house. Ramsey accounting team does
it. Okay. Taxes are have been outsourced
forever anyway. Estate planning has been
outsourced forever. Uh nuanced
litigation has been outsourced forever.
Uh, but a little thing if I need a if I
need somebody to look over a lease or uh
verify that we wrote the LOI up if we're
doing a I bought a piece of property
this week and uh you know with or I've
got it on LOI. I don't have it
contracted. So, you know, will will my
real estate team, which does not work
for Ramsey, run walk down the hall, they
do sit here, but they don't work
technically for Ramsey. Do they walk
down the hall and run it past the
general coun somebody at the general
counsel on the legal team? Probably.
Yeah. Uh, but minor stuff, but pretty
quickly if anything gets like if you're
if we're reszoning a piece of property,
my legal team here doesn't know how to
do that. I've got that's going to be an
outsource guy. I'm going to bring in a
zoning attorney that knows what the flip
they're doing and knows everybody at the
county that can walk it through cuz my
guys would be stumbling around not
knowing what they're doing down there.
General counsel would be.
Man, this that was super helpful for
those of you who are, you know, further
along in the path like some of this
stuff that we're talking about with
asset protection and entity structure.
Although it's something that you don't I
didn't I wasn't like I don't wake up
every day and be like man I can't wait
to learn about asset
protection but it's you know I did not
anticipate when I was 64 years old that
I would own zero. I don't even own my
cars. I don't own anything. Everything
is in an LLC and my wife holds the
LLC's. I actually am a very poor
individual. You know, we built this,
again, we referred to it several times,
but we we love our campus and I'm proud
of this property. We've done a good job
with it, but when we're sitting on the
interstate, six sto two six-story
buildings with big huge Ramsay Solutions
signs on them. And I thought, cuz I'm a
real estate guy, I thought, okay,
traffic count, that's branding. you
know, people going up the interstate,
they see Ramsay and they stop in and
watch the show here because it's on the
glass and it's all this customer
interaction and and it was like we're,
you know, the stuff we're teaching is
working for us. So, it's proof text for
the customer, right? And so, it's
branding and it's all positive,
positive, positive. I had no idea that
when you did something like build this
building and put it on the interstate
that you basically should have put right
under the sign the words sue me or bull
Yeah, nice bullseye. Right. bullseye. A
little bullseye. Yeah. Because I think
people, some people got from that that
this is now a a a uh a target-rich
environment. Uh and then we've had to
spend we've had to spend some money
convincing them otherwise. Um because I
don't I don't do well with this kind of
stuff. I really don't negotiate. I'm
going to pound you into dirt. And I've
got some of them that are six and seven
years now that I've been that have been
sitting in court and I'm not going to
quit. I'm going to destroy them because
I cannot stand the thievery that that
represents. It's I can't stand a thief.
I love this so much. Um I I could I
could talk probably another hour on
this, but I I'm going to pivot for the
sake of the audience. Um can you walk me
through the six stages of scaling that
you uh that you talk about in the in
your book? Well, we we came up with what
we're looking for because the
bestselling book we've ever done and and
the probably the most known thing in the
entire Ramsey brand has been the baby
steps. And that was the total money
makeover book, 12 million copies now.
And what we discovered from that
teaching people the seven baby steps,
this is what you do if you want to go
from broke to wealthy is that when
people have a clear path, it gives them
hope and they don't have paralysis of
the analysis and they don't have uh I if
you have a clear map to get to Florida,
your anxiety goes down if you're on the
way to Florida, you know, and uh if you
need a clear path. And so, uh, I didn't
have a clear path running a business.
And so, I'm kind of making it up as I
go. And I got a lot of bumps and scars
and bruises and, uh, and I went slower
than I should have cuz I didn't know
didn't know what the next step was. So,
as we've coached ourselves now through
30 plus years and, uh, about 10,000
small businesses, we're observing that
businesses go through five stages. It
starts with a treadmill stage. When
you're by yourself, you're a
soloreneur. All revenue is based on you.
All production is based on you. You
don't even really own a business. You
just own your job. Because if you don't
work, nothing happens. And so you come
home from work and you flop down on the
couch. I would when I was at that stage.
And Sharon say, "What'd you do today?" I
don't know. But I did a lot of it and
I'm exhausted. And so you just run run
run run run
run. And it's if it's to be, it's up to
me. Is not a motto, but it is the motto.
And so uh man, you get her done. Uh and
and that is fun. It's invigorating. It's
a fun time. You're still you still
believe this business thing is going to
be easy because you're naive at that
stage. Uh but it's not
sustainable. You don't meet
10year treadmill
operators because you run out of breath.
It's too hard. If you just own your own
job, they end up closing going to work
for somebody or they end up growing the
business. So, what do you do to grow?
Well, each of these stages, we figured
out there's some things you do to level
up. Uh, on that one, it's pretty simple.
Time management. You got to do what our
friend Burger at ETH says, and that is
to work on the business, not just in the
business. So, you've got to allocate
blocks of time. You got to start
blocking time and say, "All right, I got
to work. I got to have I got to start
thinking about something other than
freaking Friday and pay, you know." And
then the second thing is I got to learn
how to hire people and I got to bring on
my first folks and uh and I can delegate
to them so that someone is creating
production and someone is creating
revenue both that is not just me. So
that if I'm hurt or I'm on vacation or
uh one of my kids is sick and I need to
tend to them, the whole thing doesn't
stop. Uh and and when you do that, you
level up. Uh you know, get your first
hire. You start a little bit of baby
delegation here. Uh and you get some
good time management. You go to the
trailblazer stage. Trailblazer is just
chaotic. It's crazy. I mean, you're
trying to herd cats. You got 10, 15
people and they're running in 16
directions. Nobody knows what nobody's
doing, but we're doing a whole lot of
it. And uh it it's uh communication is
is really fun and there's a lot of
passion and a lot of zeal. It's a good
stage. I love the trailblazer stage. Uh
but again, it's it's uh eventually it's
so frenetic that eventually you you
start to go, I really want to get a
little bit more sophisticated than this
cuz this is killing me. And and so how
do you do that? Well, you start actually
doing some planning, uh which is a whole
new idea for the tactical person like
me. Uh because when in doubt, I bust
something in the nose, right? When in
doubt, I'm going to run into the wall.
Let's go do something. Not if I run into
it enough times, it'll fall over. And I
just start, you know, I got to stop
being so tactical. I got to start
thinking about long term. I got to start
really developing my first layer of
leadership inside my team. That takes
you up to the uh Pathfinder stage or
that's Pathfinder up to Trailblazer
stage. Trailblazer stage is the middle
stage of the five. I skipped one. And uh
trailblazer stage is the middle stage of
the fight. This is where you actually
where I first started hearing about
strategic thought. Um I'm so straight
commission sales guy mentality tactical
guy that when someone said we need
strategic thought that sounded like
corporate America. And I went no you
just ought to go get your work done. And
so, uh, but then I started hiring some
guys and gals that had MBAs, and they
started, I think 100% of the NBA
programs teach strategic thought as a
primary thing. And so, they start
teaching me the value of strategic
thought. They're like, "Look, you don't
have to run into the wall. If you turn
right and then turn left, you go around
the wall. It's a lot less energy. You
burn less calories." I'm like, "How'd
you know that?" Well, I got above it. I
had a 30,000 foot view. I wasn't just
looking at the dayto-day, the moment to
moment. Thank God it's Friday. Oh, God,
it's Monday. And so we blow past that
and we start actually doing strategic
thought. So they my MBAs that I hired
and other people taught me strategic
thought. I didn't know it. Uh and I
always laugh and say I taught them how
to work. So uh but uh you know so we did
that and then you moved to Pathfinder is
the fifth and that's where it's really
sweet man. You're bailing money now.
Everything you got your systems in
place, the processes in place, planning
is in place. What revenue level is
around? I'm sorry. Okay. What revenue
levels would you say like treadmill is
like 0 to a million? You know, we we
tried to attribute it to that and we
could do that with our journey, but we
really couldn't. It changes from
industry to industry. So, if I'm dealing
with a guy that's uh got one heating and
air truck and he's fixing, he's doing
HVAC, you know, when he gets the 20
trucks and 70 employees, is he there?
No, he could still be he wouldn't be
treadmill, but that doesn't necessarily
mean he's Pathfinder versus Trailblazer,
right? So, uh because he could still be
doing some of the dumb stuff three
layers below what it looks like he
should be doing. Um uh and that's that
was me. That's what I did. Uh the last
stage is what we spent a lot of our time
on, which is where we are today, and
that's the legacy stage where you talk a
lot about succession. What's your
endgame? How you going to hand off? Uh
and you've got a bench depth. It's the
ultimate bench depth is how you're going
to replace yourself and uh and move to
the family office mentality as you said
and those kinds of things. So we walk
you through those five stages, show you
a clear path and then there's six
drivers that drive those. I won't cover
them all right now. Uh but you know it's
uh uh you know it starts with personal
growth. I am the problem and I'm the
solution. I'm the thing holding the
business back at every stage. And so
I've got to get better at every stage,
right? and uh uh purpose and people, the
quality of your hires, the quality of
your culture, the quality of the
connectivity and the culture with the
core values. All those things evolve as
you go through the stages and um profit
planning and then you just cycle back
through those six drivers. We think
we've been through the six drivers at
Ramsey probably uh somewhere 10 to 15
times while we went through the five
stages. uh because they they change as
you uh you know it's like you read a
great book and then four years later you
read it again and you're a different
person so you see different things and
so you change as you go through but that
clear path between the six drivers
working to get through the five stages
has set a bunch of our folks our clients
our customers free so we decided to put
it into a book and that's what building
a business your love is.
Well, Dave, I think we're close to close
to time. Um, but I wanted to uh
personally say thank you for the impact
that I think you've made on millions of
lives. I'm sure you hear it every day,
but um I just I want to say thank you
because I think sometimes uh when you're
when you're at the top, you don't you
don't hear it as much. And so, um I
think it's it's it's real good stuff. Uh
Well, thank you, brother. No, for real.
Um, and uh, I think your heart is clear.
I think people see what your intention
behind it is. I mean, the man owns a
$600 million campus in cash. He doesn't
need your money. Um, it's nice, right?
But, uh, but but he doesn't need it. And
I think, um, I think it's really cool
what you've done. I I would love to talk
for another hour on even like going from
personal finance to, you know, the the
entrepreneurship brand. Um, but I know I
know our our our time is limited. So,
anyways, I want to say thank you again
for for for coming on the game and I'm
sure um my audience will will definitely
definitely have a couple moments of uh
PTSD here some of the stories we went
over um and maybe hopefully avoid future
PTSD by uh by taking a right and then a
left. Very cool. Well, thank you for
having me. Let's do it again. Yeah. No.
Awesome. Thank you. Hey, if you enjoyed
this conversation, this is actually a
second uh long form conversation I've
had with Dave. I had one, I think, two
years ago. It's one of the top videos on
the channel um that people seem to love.